s'est interrogé sur vos anecdotes avec
des stars puisque vous êtes des gens
connus pour certains et on s'est demandé
si vous avez une anecdote avec une star
donc on doit retrouver qui a fait dire
par exemple vous dire j'ai failli pécho
patrick bruel déjà je vous le dis c'est
une août 1 c'est une mythomane déjà ça
c'est lundi mais quelqu'un a failli
pécho patrick bruel un maxime génie
alors non pas notre vie peut-être
aurait-on d'heure en france
au maire d'
escalade
tout moi vous avez pas vu patrick
goyette s'arrête vous à moi je les fais
moi justement avez-vous oui voila je
voyage à gagner alors c'est vous tapez
sur eric nabet attendait la question
c'est est-ce que vous êtes la personne
de me dire bah ouais moi j'ai failli
pécho scarlett johansson banon deux
plateaux non mais arrêtez je me jure je
suis fan on l'attendait patrick bruel
c'est ma passion ma vie depuis je suis
gosse c'est ma vie mais je laisse sur le
support à ses nuits
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
soyons honnêtes si vous prenez bruel il
séparément le nez la bouche les yeux les
cheveux c'est pas tous mais l'ensemble
qui est très au frais c'est très
cohérent non mais l'ensemble est très
charmant
c'est bizarre autre
fait souvent dans les yeux de la main
même mais c'est comme si tu peux et sa
superbe et nomme patrick
lesur donc c'est alors tu as failli et
d'un civil un jour j'entends qu'il ya
patrick bruel atp mp bah moi d'habitude
celui-là le vendredi et là j'ai appelé
cyril j'ai fait un peu la lourdeur jeudi
cyril tu sais tu es mon ami tu gtt comme
mon frère ma chance je t'en supplie tad
mois amène moi et du cou attention a
coutume de la prog oui c'est bon ce soir
tu es en plateau j'ai dit merci mon dieu
et là on est tous là il arrive en face
de moi j'ai failli m'évanouir par terre
et cyril djiba c'est bien on va faire un
petit quart d'heure américain ce qui
attire les bonnes idées donc du coup tu
t'en fous
envoyé un texto à bout elle pourrait si
effectivement on a failli pécho magali
bertin c'est pas très mal je cachais a
raconté votre truc je vais vérifier
pendant en même temps qu'ils alors cher
patrick
quart d'heure américain et je vois la
papeterie au kaki jean valérie blais
dans celle qui est je regarde valérie je
mets deux avec moi mais je vous a tutoyé
schubert bach elle le choisit pas donc
du coup il restait que lui et moi et là
je danse avec lui sort carrément donné
ma tête se tourne personnel au maire ça
vous gêne on et puis bombes a laissé un
bisou qui habitent ce qu'il a commis
j'envoyais
mais je dois dire que je suis resté que
cette image de ce bisou qui était
presque là là bah oui ça y avoir c'est
moi aussi mais j'ai failli y voilà il ya
toujours à azé toujours et s'inquiète du
buffet moi aussi dialoguer et à préaux
dans les loges c'est vrai gernez je suis
merci par la danse et bon allez c'est
bon ça l'académie des neuf ça a failli
marcher tu vas faire ça alors donc ça
c'est magali bertin j'ai assisté à une
violente dispute entre deux stars de
téléréalité sur w9 oui c'est ça c'est
tous les jours deviennent assez bizarre
jean michel jarre michel il aime bien la
citoyenneté il a fait les anges ouais
c'est vrai jour non non
je suis allée saint geours
3les la police en voyant les un avion
pour aller jusqu'à miami je fais une
nuit là par un jour une nuit dans ma
tâche en partie sympa
c'est
des trucs mais pas des violences c'est
vous c'est moi à des banquiers fait oui
j'étais parti en vacances à dubaï
j'aborde je vais pas trop qu'il fait
d'ailleurs mais bon bref ce sujet
s'est jouée dans un très grand centre de
paris au parc aquatique
sur douala et donc je fais la 8 e et c
est devant moi se tâte lantiss la
télé réalité mais quelle dont une un
prénom de musique péter le nez sol cayo
swift à voile a demandé laurent à jazz
oui aux ballons serait bien phu et donc
j'étais là en train à temps pour faire
mon tour pour assez excité les deux
personnes et elle est restée 2h 2h 2h
dans avec eux donc j'ai fini par dire
excusez moi vous en avez pour longtemps
hélas la dame s'est retourné donc ça
sera gré c'est comme si je l'avais on en
est aux dodgers pouvoir coller qu'ériger
pas que annoncé pas non non mais c'est
pas tant de 2 ha oui c'est bien ça coûte
trop cher et donc a été très agressive
et où elle a commencé à vouloir qu'on
sorte du par ko carrément ouais ouais
ils ne reculent devant rien faire sans
salle
agréable les deux cas à
associer d'embauché c'est sûr monsieur
ça mais oui c'est moi qu'elle en bombe
s'est pas vus quittant dans tout le
monde ça oui
elle le costume a suivi la piste
[Rires]
autre façon souligné ça les amis voilà
les deux suivantes on est seulement 400
meilleurs alors j'ai vécu une rencontre
inédite avec alain delon maxime gêné
c'est dommage manif à régenter doit ce
n'est pas daniel moreau honorée un
indice
bon mois mais ces gens me non cette
génération c'est maxime maxime rey ben
non ce n'est pas
alain delon c'est janvier où nicolas
picot alaric of pas du tout non
bah oui c'est moi
à répondre dans le ciné ses scènes avec
d'autres dont j'ai honte parce que ça a
révélé une part sombre de moi c'est en
fait on est en été c'était à paris
pendant l'été à paris et il se gare au
près des invalides pour aller dîner dans
un restaurant juste l'arrière
bizarrement ils partent en vacances les
revenus en vacances ils sont que sa
voiture une très bonne voiture il avait
chauffeur et tous étaient remplis de
bagage tan bagages qui est arrivé avec
son épouse du moment et je bois de il
sort de la voiture et que son épouse il
va au restaurant qui est juste à côté
voilà et le chauffeur reste et les
chauffeurs fini de ronger comme ça et il
ferme les portes il en reste une ouverte
et moi je vois qui laisse une porte
ouverte cet emprunt de garance coût de
sa côte est il suffisait que j'aille
voir le garde du corps le chauffeur
garde du corps pour lui dire je crois
que vous avez laissé une porte ouverte
ce que tous les bagages étaient la
disposition il avait plus qu'à voler
quoi et au lieu d'aller le dire vous
garde du corps j'ai attendu que le
garde-corps ce bar et j'ai été voir un à
deux longs comme suce boules de deux
matchs ce que vous
monsieur dont je suis désolé mais je
crois qu'on votre voiture est restée
ouverte etc et voilà ce qui devait
arriver arriva il a foutu une énorme
race grâce aux gardes du corps à seurre
face voilà aux gardes du corps langeland
10 ans prenant à témoin les enfants dès
qu'on dira plus petit personnel et sert
à quelque chose à faire c'est de
conduire à fermer des portes à clé et il
est fait la moitié du boulot sur le coup
j'étais super g n'est pas ce que nous
savons le garde du corps était vraiment
il vous dit de baisser la tête serra et
j'espérais peut-être je ne sais pas quoi
dans le nom une récompense à manon jeu
que je n'ai pas eu égard à lévis foot et
compétents
du corps à cause de moi c'est fait
j'espère que mr fait évident mais ne
vous inquiétez pas
le délai d'option
alors ensuite
franchement ou aux mêmes moyens moyens
voilà elles sont tous travaux monroe
l'instant et bepa début des travaux des
missions quoi voilà
mais bon alors j'ai dansé avec allongée
avec une desperate ça c'est nico sont
donc des impôts les connaître
il ya carrie bradshaw non alors
quelqu'un d'autre
avec laquelle avec laquelle maxime j'ai
dansé avec linkedin à l'hallali city of
man jia une dizaine d'années à mon avis
ça va jouer on habite à l'est il est
allé à universal monsieur y avait un
truc à cet effet bonjour eu beaucoup de
victoires
mythomane pas du tout non non non
abonnés photo ni rien cette hausse des
cours de ce même jour une star mike est
dense avec gainey et franchement comme
dirait cyril je me coupe une gouge et
mes
[Applaudissements]
défauts c'était elle c'était la folie
ouais c'est en fait s'il était sûr et
barbra streisand qui a eu quelques
minutes
étonnée je fais je fais des blagues
s'est un peu fait pas ou fait wow
l'eau
ne serait pas si mal alors on y va j'ai
accosté miguel sardo complètement ivre
de base on sait qui c'est c'est bon
c'est ce qu'un instant les mecs vont
bientôt alors c'est parce que j'étais
dans l'avion oui
mais parce qu'on si j'ai très peur de
l'avion donc du coup j'avais bien un
petit coup c'était avant la star ac je
sais que michel sardou va être alors je
rappelle qu'on boit toujours avec
modération et pas comme cette personne
je cherche un petit gabarit de verre et
je chantonne donc bon bref je vous je
monte dans l'avion je crois michel
sardou je sais que c'est le parrain de
la star ac qui va arriver moi je n'ai
pas encore la réponse je ne sais pas si
je suis prise qu'est ce que je fais je
me dis shop l'occasion chante au moins
huit on doit lancer
commencé à chanter bourré et
son poids est un peu tout
il va chanter je vais t'aimer c'est pour
ça qu'ils absorbent des bouées l'heure
où les plus demandés alors très
gentiment monsieur venu me voir et m'a
dit mettez vous à sardou aimerait se
reposer si vous pouvez arrêter de chat
web et j'imagine
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine sans tabou michel sardou qui
donc dans l'avion tranquille qui en
vendent ronfler
c'est un pari montréal
s'est parlé en corse ah oui la corse
vous bah je faisais des allers road avec
comme lui car il est là quand il a vu
david villa en corse je suis un des
films à parité
n'a pas mal la bac mais chaque assiette
de la noc j'étais invité si vous
n'habitez c'est possible depuis lors
j'ai assisté à la donc là il ya
vachement voitures éco layada c'est
quelqu'un
de bien dit les gens alors dans des
divisions et acquisitions pour quel
motif en tête du sien alors tu es savic
chantal goya tient beaucoup de problèmes
avec le fisc ahola et donc je vois un
café chez elle à four que puisqu'elle
avait une maison à fourquevaux des
scénarios c'est la préférée de donner le
mot exactement
tout d'un coup ça sonne sonne dehors il
ya trois personnes qui arrivent qui
rentre dans la maison et qu'il commence
à prendre les tableaux les uns de leurs
inventions des photos qui font des trucs
c'est là et moi j'étais là s'il est réel
et et puis on capte à lui arriver ça lui
arrive et 150 x et une femme incroyable
d'ailleurs charquiya parce qu'elle est
revenue de très très loin m énormément
de problèmes financiers il faut savoir
que le couple debout et goya ont été les
plus grands revenus de la sacem pendant
des années à ses dépens des combats
cassinga sinon mettant l'éditeur
l'éditeur sega au
québec chez chantal goya ou type jeantet
est une amie elle habitait fourqueux
juste à côté pour
évoquer des pour quelques jours que le
diplôme ceci l'embryon
humain très loin très bien merci manu et
commet pas mal pas mal
oui était la tête de turc que des stars
internationales donc c'est dans ce
bâtiment pascal parce qu'il veut nous
raconter il a fait la star arena sûr
qu'il y avait beaucoup de stars tubes et
qu'il a fait un tube international
chanter avec toi une merde
j'avais que forcément vous dis lui c'est
ça merci on parle
[Applaudissements]
vous racontez juste après la pluie est
arrivée une aventure incroyable que je
n'ai jamais raconté avec abou kylie
minogue un truc de goda pas débridé pour
que
stephano sucy en brie et ça a failli
ripper à four que aller